c'est fantastique en fait j'essaye
d'henri le raid avec le téléphone mais
c'est pas simple c'est pas c'est vrai je
me bats à temps en temps je vois je vois
le chat de l'autre côté histoire de bien
voir je vais essayer d'être bien sûr
ok donc ça c'est bon maintenant je mens
je vais m'occuper des caps fab et c'est
le moment qui me fait le plus peur en
vrai une fois qu'on aura passé sa fab on
sera bon déjà toi tu me fais c'est ce
toi qui me fait le moins peur dans tout
le truc donc déjà je te mets dans la la
la je flippe là
alphabet là et maintenant le plus dur
femmes
le moment de vérité j'ai montré tout à
l'heure aux gars avec ma caméra le la
technologie ouais ok tu sens tu sens que
si si si même là j'arrive à ce prix mais
tu sens qu'on aura jamais de problème en
fait ouais tu sens que si même là on
passe en fait ouais en fait c'est
terrible on a cassé dans le même temps
kenyon président hu est alors attends
ouais ok bah ouais c'est exact ils ont
raison mais on va te retrouver très vite
fait et pas mieux en fait mais à qui on
doit attendre maintenant l'avouent
montrant décevant est là de retour en
temps on t'entend contentant fab nickel
c'est bon c'est bon j'ai dit oui de
partout on m'envoie des wii dans le chat
on t'entend c'est bon
fab il me reste une dernière manie pas
faire si je la réussite fab
si je me sens comme un rappel le film
sur lens sur neil armstrong sur la lune
ouais ben apollo 13 non vraiment sûr
enfin vraiment le verbe fait le mec qui
suis issu issue est finalement enfin
tout tout se passe bien quoi je suis pas
loin enfin je suis ado doit la fab
je suis à je suis à ramener un truc vert
le tout en bas je suis à quelques
encablures de réussir là n'oubliez pas
de respirer quand même tout ça quoi
ne dites pas que c'est pas vrai j'ai
réussi waouh
du coup on a tous en haïti cas où on
highway cela sert syndicats ou
aujourd'hui attention c'est important
attend c'est pas c'est pas tout à fait
finie mais presque à une ambulance qui
part bon bah le match est parti on a
juste raté la première minute du coup
fab
c'était une sorte de fou ces quatre
partis du fou puis bah du coup il ya des
offres spéciales à sébeillon
relativement symétrique et dames sont
échangés puis voilà quoi
et disons un repère du fab c'est fou ça
non que j'aie plus d'image
by ap une image ouais ouais mais attends
attends mais ça la rigueur on va les
régler en dernier en fait en fait on va
même perdre les joueurs parce que pour
follow hikaru je vais avoir un problème
mais a tant fait on a réussi le plus dur
on a réussi le plus dur en fait on a
réussi le plus dur fab
ne t'inquiète pas ça va bien se passer
tout ce qui est caméra tout ce qu'on
demande échiquier oui bien sûr général a
en fait on est un vrai on est on à une
encablure de t'avoir de pas de pattes
partent visuellement et d'avoir tout lé
un attelage quoi alors la fab
je ne touche plus à je ne touche plus à
rien je te laisse commenté on va là
excusez moi monsieur
il ya vraiment tout enjeu tchèque il ya
vraiment tout il ya vraiment tous assez
extraordinaire parfait j'ai quasiment
même envie de regarder le live sur mon
téléphone parce que c'est plus beau sur
le téléphone que en vrai je vais le
mettre là mais du coup j'ai pris part
une petite machine à café derrière comme
jean-mi carreau à habitat machine on la
voit pas est ce qu'on la voit pas très
bien alors qui est favori de ce match on
n'a pas le temps d'en parler pour moi
c'est vrai c'est ce que les robots ont
fait leur truc
écoute j'aimerais bien pouvoir te le
dire mais ça me demanderais d'aller
d'aller trouver mais je suis sûr qu'ils
ont mis carbou favoris les robots voilà
je pense c'est sûr vas-y wes il ya des
trucs à faire je te laisse je vais voir
si je vois quelque chose pour le chrono
est bien parti à attention c'est
important à ce très important ça pour
être bien sûr botte bien sûr je crois
que carros ans est favori mais voilà on
nous en fait la patte la pâte fab elle
dit quoi la pâte fable a pas de
sélectionneur à l'icam victoire de soan
en pied du corps le chat quand même
qu'ils aient la nasa qui guettent dans
l'ombre se dit bon bah j'en sais rien en
fait
johra dire 100 m c'est vrai que les deux
dernières finales des speechs
n'accueille battue sauf pendant leur
historique et tout ça il a un petit
petit ascendant mais d'un autre côté
souris labatut karlsen no skilling
européenne il a gagné le championnat des
etats-unis dans la forme du moment
sochaux est là quoi c'est donc non je
sais pas je pensais plutôt plus 55 ans
dont 4 c'est dur de dire clairement à
quoi s'il faut se mouiller alors quand
même se dominer karl scène sodomie
ménaka aux championnats des états unis
c'est c'est quand même une s'était pas
même cadence mais peu importe l'histoire
n'en mettrait très dominateur m
non mais coûte peut-être que c'est là
une nouvelle période forte pour socom il
a vu en 2016 sont dormir un peu donc je
sais pas trop quoi on y lit c'est la
nive de naka il part avec un désavantage
ah oui mais en plus il a battu il avait
battu karl scène le jour de son
anniversaire à wesley
exactement ici oui bon bah des
anniversaires son délire il n'existe
chez scm et 72 28 pour naka non mais ça
c'est beaucoup c'est un peu trop bas en
fait ce pourrait être vrai sans compter
la forme du moment
c'est ça le truc si tu vois je suis un
bookmaker il me dit pas ça les cotes jeu
par les sursauts 50 aujourd'hui on est
on est d'accord qu aucun bookmaker n'est
venu te voir quoi non non je peux
pourquoi mais ce serait bon en fait que
tu aies des bookmakers qui viennent te
voir avant les matches oui fab talus
coup au tibet qui viennent te faire
chier tu vois ce israël te poser des
questions quoi j'avais cette coutume ou
tunis pas arriver avant tout les matchs
qu'on a vécu un truc qui se passe ils
viennent ita/kat apporte quoi fab pour
avoir le bon truc mais les mieux quand
même un haka pendant la première non
avec le foot est roi
ouais tu poses jeu j'aurais bien une
petite nul je prendrai les blancs quand
même quand je sais pas comment le
cueillir et venger 4 pour quoi faire
en fait il est venu chasser le fou ou
trois je crois
c'est que l'alcool le coulis demande
s'il faut b3 vaut une minute on ne sait
pas
après anna qu'à ça et qui sent il sait
bien échauffés hier il faisait un bon
sparring ouais ouais un choc contre un
joueur français
quand même assez assez prometteur comme
joueur français il n'a pas tari d'éloges
il a pas il n'a pas tari d angers là il
a par yann des boums
parce que c'est bien mais pas mauvais
après ça qu'il aura un clouage à
supporter pendant quelques coups et puis
sépare de la part de fou quand même et
il y avait quatre ans l'air aussi à tout
moment faire d'ailleurs je me demande si
je prends du hockey j'aurais pris une
cavale tout reprendre 17 et peut-être
trop ça du coup tu reviens en d1 ou pas
où tu t'y chambre est attendu en d1
probablement bon sapeur cicinho attend
ici chaque jour je vous indiquais et b6
aussi comme sur wii mais non ça va pas
du tout il a fait le tour des vitres
peuvent être donc je pense à tort que
c'est malin parce que ça bouge pas ton
[ __ ] toute attaque toujours b4 tu as
une menace peut-être à vérifier ce
serait de faire ces cinq ans mais c'est
si simple mais tu l'as eu cinq sous
pression je vais ce cinq ans leur alors
qu'elle prenait 5 qu'est ce que
ce que il ya du fou j'ai fait ça parce
qu'il faut prendre b4 menace ou c3
infogen semaine ça a l'air fort il ya
tellement de clouage après 9,4 mais bon
y su quoi faire j'ai 5 tu peux faire
c'est à dire autour duquel angers 4
verset 5
jardé des français froid 5 puis on prend
tous et 6 on va partir là dedans soit
fou pour hommes et 4 soit fou g7 en mai
4 juin sous ces trois ans plus un c'est
vrai que de hockey où je salue cette
voie y4 s'est cassé committed et
joaillerie quatre thèmes port
il veut faire fougue et 3 pour enlever
son poids je sais bien joué ça aussi
durcir tac tac tac bishop bichri tictacs
et utah key to bishop's yang tseu benoît
baby rock dj whoo kid rock diwan
mais c'est marrant parce que je suis sûr
qu'il se dit ça en faisant sa partie
mais brooke diwan move bishop big three
il est marrant naka quand il fait ça ils
dansent pas encore moi je fait il est
tout petit sur mon écran je n'arrive pas
trop à le voir en vrai bonjour à tous je
juste sur le truc c'est ce que met sur
le chat mais l'assomption de plus maka
c'est bizarre parce que ça semblait
tellement tendue à tenir il a réussi
qu'à maintenir le pion après oui je suis
d'accord avec toi que break et détroit
ce train truc tu vas leur père de quoi
mais oui tour 17 ya eu 5 tandis qu'à
trier des trois petites nul voila donc
j'ai commencé des routes du seven nights
out of seven draw very low qui fera
moins seul et a du coup à l'espagnol
wesley choix que j'ai beaucoup de tours
on my knees dans les tendons la main tu
dois être très au fait je sais très au
fait t'as regardé les parties à fond et
tout pas noël vont à fond c'est un grand
monsieur
regardez ce qui se passe à et du coup
pas une grand chose ah ah
[Musique]
il était pas mal je peux en fait même
car c'est le dernier jour a changé la
plus jeune 4 5
ouais bon il sait pas qui est qui était
si dominique sam mais ou du ku'damm deux
mois je suis côté n'a qu'à ça me trouble
un peu mais je suis côté n'a qu'à terme
aussi les noirs en bas à 8 nouveaux
gradins gouvernail nouvelle avec joie
cette demi finale vendredi
outre carlsen est ce que tu penses que
carla n'est que la face aux sciences pas
les favoris quoi gros je sais pas
peut-être 65,35 un truc comme ça
après ça veut rien dire en fait les
chiffres enfin ian wheeler quoi c'est 50
soyez en solitaire et je le confirme
mais sarah pas à complètement là pour
les noirs il a fait le petit dessine co
ceci parce que tu fais quoi tu fais du
pion prend du plomb puis on prend des
sinko puis on prend des think aux dons
de cabaye heures mais je sais pas ses
positions c'est tellement complexe est
tellement de ramifications que tu peux
aussi prendre prendre prendre ses sets
et après
mais si les blancs ils réussissaient à
jour un truc genre edc d installer un
pion des cas tu vois à jouer la
structure là contre des 5 17
à sète pardon genre si tu fais un pion
prend des cinq puis on prend des 5 mai
que réussissait à mettre ton purement
des cas tu sais pour jouer cette
structure ah oui abbas moment là c'est
la structure aux sources est mieux pour
les blancs mais est-ce que ça suffit
genre pour précéder j'avoue même pas ce
que ça c'est ce que tu peux obtenir de
mieux je crois peut-être regarder puis
en d3 en fait si on a ce genre de trucs
pour mettre les uns kavala en d4 et
dames f3 et je suis pas il pas de la
case ou quatre on en est loin
on n'avait pas encore bas surtout que
soient prises des 5 si j'ai envie de
prouver qu'il veut dire quoi
alors que c'est que ça va vous faire des
tours problème si c'est peut-être mais
ce que j'étais en train de garrigue à
lyon prend 1,4 peut-être tout reprend
1,6 g prend un f6 bah je sais pas de
suite mais et damages tête
voilà un truc comme ça pour ramener la
tour lequel l'hiver f5 peut être un jour
bon 5
je peux ça marche mais a noté que le
pion à vii sera cloué un an ses
variantes là donc il ya dame g6 qui
vient c'est sûr et chacun juste pour
dire qu'il faut trouver un bout mais ça
peut être fait une avance à peu à tanger
essayer de montrer une variante il a
pris j'essaie juste de montrer la
position ils diraient prêts roi g7 peut
juste être tour fr le bon cours avec
l'idée de ramener un par contre est
alors attends ça j'avais pas pensé du
tout
donc il a fait des quatre dames cette
tour f4 ouais donc c'était pas du tout
son idée ya dorion que l'on pouvait
attendre manque parfois besoin rajoute
temps à chaque coup alors ça augmente
très peu ces deux secondes à chaque fois
un truc comme ça c'est une même place
même une voix donc s'ils jouent super
vite ils vont gagner une petite seconde
puis sinon à gueye même s'ils ont pas
super vite ils ont toujours plus une
seconde mais tu verras pas toujours pris
vraiment du temps et normalement la
difficulté de cette cadence c'est que
remonte jamais quant à plus trois opus 4
secondes tu peux quand même remonter la
plus une fois que tu es tombé sous les
10 secondes tu survis seulement mais ça
devrait être joué longtemps western est
de survivre longtemps mais tu peux at
aura pas le temps de remonter en fait ça
peut être ça peut donner des fins de
partie complexe
l'annoncé évidence être mieux de tentes
à plus de temps tu le sais d'axelera ben
quoi après ça donne des fins de parties
marrante à regarder le plus un mail à
lille qu'elle a quand même pris un pion
onaka au final il a pris le pion à bah
ouais je sais pas si au lieu de 9 04
mais beaucoup mieux non vous n'en
remarque n 3 est quand même fort un ba
en fait c'est pas si simple de bouger je
pense c'est mieux je sais pas trop ce
que ça va donner sur de nordine une
petite activité et les blancs moncayo
trois alphabets trois ils vont doubler
tour il a des petits trucs mais
j'imagine sur un jeu bien précises après
c'est le genre de truc aussi qu'ils sont
double tranchant c'est pas genre mieux
pour les noirs et sajoo nul ou bien des
noirs là ça joue vraiment pour pour tous
les résultats parce que tu en principe
autorisée puis on prend qui est des cinq
qui en prend le chemin
d'ailleurs que tourcoing fc ce que c'est
pas un c'est sûrement s'y regarde juste
maman
parce que champion prend qui a aidé 5 on
va attaquer la damer le pion par les
tours assez salée donc il bien joué tour
à 6 il vient de défendre à 9,6 je vois
c'est vite l'anact même si nous venons
pour qui je suis célia maso au passage
pour qui je suis je sais pas en fait je
passe car favori soirée en mai sous un
groupe de hip hop
moi j'ai envie de dire je suis souvent
pour la surprise quoi c'est tellement
rare que tu vois et après à la fin du
match je suis un peu neutre mais au
début du match j'ai bien envie de l'être
pour sow d'être pour sow au début après
oui que le meilleur gagne
menaka c'est qu'il est tout le temps
final donc tu as envie de le voir un peu
suez qui t'a quitte à remonter à la fin
et a gagné au dernier moment comment et
qui quoi ya pas de vous prouver sa
carrière la dame qui couvrent faudrait
un look à troyes le mans mais fou 4 aura
peut-être des idées de dessins qu'il
faut acheter chez avec un joueur aussi
il prend de la tour st cloud et
probablement moitié petit nul ça tout
est changé en russie ce choix de tours
s'appelle up dans la finale deux pions à
dos d'homme pour l'instant mais moi je
suis là les têtes prendre deux dames je
pensais qu'il était de faire dame prend
aussi offert la finale de pions mais oui
peut-être finale de dame aidé à me 5,2
me ses carreaux que ça c'est
complètement nul
il n'y a même pas de monde ou un des
deux joueurs attendent dans celle là
quoique n'a pas peut-être le petit plan
roi de ces trois des six dames c6 mais
bon dans votre paroisse où il va arriver
vite avec seront aussi oui puis de toute
façon illicite et de père pète et c'est
donc ça peut pas marcher mais je voulais
dire que si avec quelqu'un qui s'est pas
risqué à rennes ans même pas le mot en
fait je risque même pas fait dire à
personne qui risque ici les petits trucs
ap la haye voilà deux petites nuls pour
commencer
j'adore majestic sommes prêts j'ai
l'impression qu'il fait des ce qui
tendait des grimaces je vois tout petit
sur mon écran mais je sens mes virées
king of seven queen bee seventure qingli
séverine bisevac cheikh quindi forte
chaque aïd ya laissé beaucoup et je
surkiffe sa live quand il fait ça a
collé sur ces petites grimaces cissé qui
vient d'amener cette bulle au prochain à
toronto michael druker batta mais vers
quoi
[Musique]
mais c'est tellement sûrs qu'ils font ça
mais en réalité je suis sûr qu'il en
fait il fait juste il fait juste cool et
du temps pour aller vers le bullet quoi
c'est sûr
en fait si primitif que ça faisait signe
qui arriveront tout penguin bat boulet
taille du nord non mais le truc c'est
que l'extraordinaire dacca c'est qui
paraît qu'en trois minutes en fait
sourit pierre faure il a le meilleur
ratio score surtout les tous les matchs
de suite chez si tu prends tous les
genres toutes les saisons allez c'est
génial du coup ils parent ferai c'est
quoi mais n'a qu'à me fait kiffer sur
des trucs comme ça aperçoit en accablant
ça repart tous plus fous ces quatre une
fée qui fait à une clé qui fait
navigation ce genre de délire bon on a
plus ou moins il se joue que je veux les
ouvertures blanc noir c'est un débat
gros débat théorique
ouais bon ça envoie à cinq cavaliers c4
c5 ya eu 3 il va faire un
cinquième au débat jusque là cavalier f5
ouais voilà ce qui s'est passé de 24 ans
de cavale et ouais c'est plutôt bien
joué on a toujours des idées pour
attaquer vergès est juste façon tu
prends pas mal de cas se faire toucher 5
fait un clouage tu verras c'est plutôt
bien joué probablement en fait que so il
doit peut-être carte des preuves
ok vous pour être exact mais ce débat
c'est ce qu'est venu parce que c'est pas
une vision très très très ouverte en
fait de la peur de fouet n'est pas
encore super shirt et en gros tout
cavalier tu peux pas lutter ça va être
ça va être encore assez égal après il ya
de la vie dans la position
et puis plus rien quand il prend quand
elle ne l'espace
il ya ceux qui se barre non je sais pas
ce qui fait un il remettait sa caméra
derrière pardon ouais
attention petit rappel à l'ordre je
ramais avec approche de disqualification
il joue il joue sur un très grand écran
en fait vraiment très très grands ils
sont officiellement tout petit devant
lui sans décroît et l'immense quoi et
j'ai l'échiquier francs 1 8ème de
l'écran ayez bien quoi mais je crois que
c'est mieux de jouer sur un petit
échiquier c'est pas le premier que je
vois faire sa ba pour le pilote moins de
distance web lui-même que tu vois plus
l'échiquier en entier
[Musique]
l'idée en fait c'est de le savoir tout
l'échiquier en un coup d'oeil mais c'est
à dire qu'il est plus petit que un
échiquier taille normale comme on a nous
c'est difficile à évaluer puisque avec
la camerata les perspectives ou quoi
mais ça donne l'impression que wild un
grand écran et qui le met à ces petits
l'échiquier si t'as pas idiot non au
prolongement ça
j'ai pas trop étudié comment optimiser
la taille de l'échiquier mais pour
l'acuité à vis du l6 d'alger trois bons
mois ces substances à prendre les blancs
de ses positions je sais pas j'ai juste
il faut avoir la peur de fou mais bon
mais c'est juste ce objections sur 30
avant chose au warm comment quand j'ai
les noirs dans ce genre de position fait
je joue pas si mal mais je me sens tout
le temps tu sois je me sens sous
pression en fait je sais pas je veux
dire à raismes et fucile plus active un
jour ça va être dur qua non à l'om c'est
un peu le manque de perspective avec les
nerfs qu'est ce que je veux faire quand
on sait pas trop mais tu vois tu as du
tour à des mythes et b5
à rome on va faire des coups des 50 est
le faire avant d'ailleurs moi je ferai
un des prêtres sont pourquoi je vais le
prendre soin des producteurs mais les
puits b 5 et 3 des 8 es truc comme ça
mais thuram a peut-être au fond b6 tu
peux juste optimiser un peu tes pièces
mais j'ai pas de plan pour me dire ok je
vais attaquer ça je vais me mettre comme
ci comme ça après un moment j'ai juste
attendre puisque et pénible ces grands
maîtres dès que tu fais des oeufs des
oeufs comme tu as les fous on sait de c1
il contrôla super bien la colonne des
donc n'a aucune perspective sur la
colonne des jeux entre port louis a de
fait refouler fait après avec les blancs
il a quoi comme perspective bas essayer
de faire des quatre noms mais on doit
jamais marcher mais oui hélas sur vous
prend 1,6 à cavaler hc incarne attention
ça pourrait sembler yoff bishop et x6
knight rises est ce que j estime qu à y
dire ça peut exister avec quadrillage
simcoe cavaliers f4 notre sokohi qu'un
mecosun bishop diwan cadre des quatre
fers quad et 4 c 5
faites un truc tu peux toujours faire du
cou à ces cinq cieux c'est faire plus on
prend ces trois et b4 pour gagner la
caisse des cas les goban ils demandent
si cole phelps pourra schisteux tu peux
montrer alors attends le truc c'est que
quand je monte c'est dur et je montre
avec les flèches la forge et donc fou
prend la fuite cavaliers pro fasciste
cavaliers h 5 1 défendra g7 et attaque
et attaquent aussi la faute à la crise
il faut fait le voyage suite du coup ils
s'arrêtent du vis-à-vis bon mais moi je
prendrais en d4 que je sais pas non mais
ce que tu te fais pas jouer les cases
noires genre pions fromage nous mais je
fais raphia de faire des trucs j'ai
l'impression que la supériorité
numérique sur cases noires du coup à la
droite à fo à 5 c'est bien joué
allez y je voudrais vont bien ouais mais
là là le truc de d4 bessin b5 des 4 x 5
c'est c'est vraiment bien joué ma note
le pouvoir à m cavale de huit pieds
c'est ça qui est aussi c'est par exemple
a si bien réussi si les royals il
contrôle des quatre f4 je ferais bien
ces cinq aussi bien en fougue et si ce
que je sais pas ce qu'il veut exactement
mais admettons disons qu'il veut a
minima déjà sur ses dettes à fou prend
ravitaille bernard latour bienvenus
pourquoi pas directement fait trouvé six
mois c'est pas mal ça te fait gagner un
peu de temps tu as mis un coup de
pression à la tour en d1 pas forcément
mieux placé ouais mais tu vois c'est ce
truc qui est très dur à gérer en blitz
c'est quand le mec fait pas de fautes
c'est pas forcément les meilleurs coups
mais il te fait rien mais pas craqué
puis cas et 17 qui va arriver
et puis en gros faut à 5 tours des infos
b6 tff au v6 direct ou quoi ça change
pas grand chose mais il a remis un petit
coup de pression c'est bien joué en fait
que réfléchir
ouais il peut
ce qui peut aussi tenter un genre de
jessica va les acheter un an c'est trop
bizarre ça fait bien si c'est trop
bizarre
la prime a donc bon faut des quatre
paraîtrait logique quand même autour des
8 oui bon c'est pareil alors de coup
droit h1 pour partir du vis-à-vis et
fous des quatre ans ça c'était écrit
et maintenant s'il réussit à mettre le
car est né en russie c'est mieux pour
les noirs il veut absolument faire 4
s'activer mais payant jusque là la
partie de soi elle est juste énorme pour
du blitz est énorme mais maintenant
c'est beau parce que l'état les pions
des 3/4 c'est ça ressemble un peu comme
dans les françaises à l'envers c'est un
jeu six des cinq là qui est bloqué il te
bloque sur noir et il te laisse le fou
de cases blanches qui ne sert à rien là
c'est un mass attack la technique vous
faites le jeu des couleurs
ouais bon après faut conclure parce que
on est mieux avec les normes ya aucun
doute mais encore faut-il gagner et
regarde il veut jouer la majorité à elle
dame basket bien c'est quand tu fais b4
tu vas plus ou moins forcé plus grands
fous bombes et quatre jeux seront
préparés de ça il en larmes
tu fais quoi tu as un carillon ans est
ici c'est peut-être d'ailleurs qui sait
si cet avantage c'est que si tu es fou
prend des quatre pour reprendre du
cavalier à ça j'ai pas aimé à moins
qu'ils aient un tour d un arrêt non tour
j'ai pas aimé mais en fait il ya
peut-être tour à tour dire sûr mais je
crois surtout revient ici je suis en
train de calculer en fait en parlant et
je vous dise pasqua sur tours d un tour
b 1 bat pas grand chose ok ces messages
sur prend b2 et j'arrête le pion et à
leroy damrémont c'est fini
quelle partie la sortie du jeu
impressionnant non mais vraiment
impressionnant femme là franchement
c'est 6 surtout tu n'as qu'à ah oui j'ai
regardé moi aussi ce streamer france est
très talentueux et je sais comment
contrer la nage dorff à y rentrer dans
cette variante alors à l'époque c'était
pas super bien réputé ça pour les
noir mais depuis j'ai un peu regardé en
fait ça va mal époque on te recommandait
pas du tout de laisser g5 en fait pas
entre commandes et vraiment le dessine
qu est de jouer à dragon c'était aussi
une des deux bonnes lignes ou alors
c'est garry kasparov qu'il avait fait et
c'était justement pas terrible et
c'était un des points positifs de jouer
la ligne c'est quand m quand tu jouer
contre quelqu'un le matin qui est pas
trop le temps de se préparer dans la
base
oui car il a joué ça ça doit pas être
mal en fait c'est mal
c'était une partie vendue sous kasparov
eu malheureusement d'ailleurs pour les
gens qui jouent et cette ligne parce que
s'il avait gagné sur la défendre à ce
titre on aurait pensé que c'était bien
et en fait ouais normalement ça en fait
pourquoi parce qu'ils te disent effet à
l'époque après évidemment ça a été ré
analysé maintenant quoi mais il te
disais que du coup tu as eu du mal à
lutter avec les noirs pour la casse des
cinq du coût à le tour j'en étais
complètement justifiée par rapport à la
poussée curiosité j'ai 6 mai que pas ça
faisait pas sensé qui préférait jouer
avec des structures chez venin gars
l'époque en plus les structures avec
l'option réussissent donc ça il n'aimait
pas du tout tu dis oui qui a perdu le
contrôle de dessins que les blancs sont
déjà mieux
bon ok on pourrait dire le même
commentaire sur n'importe quelle des 6,5
ouais mais là le truc en fait c'est que
dans l'esprit ce qu'ils veulent dire
c'est que tu as joué par ben en fait oui
part du postulat que tours g15 ou de
merde
ouais c'est trouver un truc qui égalise
très clairement où limite tu joues
pressoir de déclin est en fait c'est
peut-être juste pas moi bâton rouge r
c'est pas plus mal qu'un autre nom mais
sa part en moi enfin le problème c'est
que oui comme j'ai analysé le truc que
je les joue quoi et qu'on va toujours
dit que c'était mieux pour les blancs
voiture visuellement je n'arrive pas à
penser que les blancs sont pas mieux moi
je me dis bon ben je vais faire un fou
ces quatre là tu vois j'aime parler
poliment quand même à méthodes qui sont
juste mieux là j'en sais rien fait mais
moi je sais pas j'ai toujours joué moi
du côté blanc ce genre sicilienne en
fait ça me plaît forcément mai
mais bon après je sais pas ce juste pas
si nate mclouth et quatre pouces et
quatre sur qui prend 1,4 g dames f3 et
je vais commencer à jouer la case f7
taton flou non protégés en russie ce qui
commence à faire peur on a des idées de
pardon mince à temps c'est du coup à
chaque fois que je clique sur un truc
gtk les caméras mais oui tu menaces du
cavalier c7 fou prend aussi ce qui peut
se résoudre en faites quoi jouez pas
ticketpro au 4e va faire c'est que ça va
très mal
ok prend le cadre d'un f3 salaires qatar
et ça va probablement très bas nous fait
un jeu d'erreurs détrompe toi qui
viennent c'est tout à fait normal qu'ils
ne connaissent pas c'est tout à fait
normal et green dragon
bah ouais faille maire de grasse est
partout et quand je regarde sur mon
téléphone en fait je vois mieux sur le
téléphone moi c'est tout petit mais sur
le fond je vais bien voir tour à 5 tout
ce à quoi on n'était pas bien fait bon
alors elles sont plus orageux passer
l'examen d'un fils bon sait jamais si
nette mais ouais positionnement on aime
bien les blancs
en fait le truc c'est que ce soit il est
complètement ce vous mais je sais de
mieux le mettre dans votre truc c'est
qu'il est doué chez lui en fait c'est
pour ça qu'on est là je regarde le
visuel de ce qu'on fait mais
étrange
patricia excuse moi je suis allé voir le
visuel jeu oui mais en fait je peux rien
y faire
non en fait sauter son qu'il est
vraiment beaucoup plus gros que naka
mais oui tu peux pas j'étais en train de
réfléchir c'est est modifiable mais en
fait non pas ça c'est quoi c'est de
l'anglais la ville est très proche de la
caméra de son côté en fait par rapport à
naka et donc c'est qu'enfin tu peux pas
équilibré spikes libre à blanc fait peu
importe là
ouais c'est bien triste fin à cahill
accepte d'être un peu moins bien mais
c'est le mieux en fait ce qu'il a fait
mettre un peu moins bien que rambo donc
juste pour dire n'ya pas fou pranger
caps qui est cloué et y'a pas fou prend
des cinq pour échanger les dames en
force ce qu'il écrit aussi ses jolies
quoi c'est un double clivage y en a un
qui est légal mais il n'est pas
conseillé pour ces sept attendait 8
voilà pour enlever un des clous âge mais
la soupe quand des cinq faim menacent
ils menacent dé changer quoi bon là non
il veut vous prendrez vous proches
disent peut-être pas tout de suite mais
il faut prendre si on prend un fils d'un
prend ensuite d'un bref si c'est rentrer
en live filmé pour mater ou des ou des
fous g5 giratoire pour fuite qui aurait
pu être un coup à priori pourquoi barça
6 apparemment il faut g5 qui devrait
faire mal
ouais donc non ça c'est désagréable page
avec les normes
je sais pas combien mes lordi votre look
mais soit il ressort quand même une
grosse game une nouvelle vrai nom mais
en fait il ya un très bon style si le
maintien va t'y fais pas de conneries
tactique
le justice joue plus ou moins vite dans
son style sans faiblesse à bien placer
les pièces mettre la pression tranquille
où il est pénible avec la macquarie
grimace à la même mais moi je les ai vus
mais même en tout petit tu vois la
grimace puisque fou de bishop dit
l'italien comment on termine avec juste
tourache un tour h1 je pense pour
acheter un timbre et 7 ckoi le wi fi ni
jusqu'à naka et grimacé et complètement
commence à regarder autre chose sauge
par joan of pain je veux pas qu'on gagne
la jouant juste qui perd en fait ce que
t'as pas j'essaie théâtre reprend régis
papa tout reprendre et 6,6 à tout
reprendre et 6 java tour à charlie adam
g7 s'engage sans tarder et après on fait
peut-être que c'est pas si grave parce
que norbu choix mais je viens tu es plus
mieux 5e à temps il ya des amis j'ai 7
au prochain quand même oui mais dommage
5 et je sais pas pas encore
tu vas perdre est de 1
mais oui freedom g7 aussi ça c'est clair
chez colmater gens me font des satif en
deçà de dire si fulham 1-3 elle est
grosse et plus grosse gaffe un étrange
le fou prend 1,6 ouais surtout qui a pas
besoin quoi en fait c'est à s'être gavé
ouais c'est face à lui ce n'est pas
typique de soupe quand tu es mieux tu
veux continuer mieux à jouer tranquille
pendant longtemps et si tu vas pour ça
qu'une pièce ou que tu faut gagner sur
le champ parce qu'il n' blues mais pas
pour profile un fou quel choix qui tente
un petit piège sympa surtout prend f2i à
tourcoing f2
pour preuve deux dames e63 fuite et tour
h3 je pense je suis 100 je suis sans
ordi parce que là je le leur dis n'a pas
la capacité de mettre l'ordi aussi
douceur et de tout faire donc tout ce
que je dirai à il veut peut-être des
dames à are il veut peut-être des pièges
encore à base de damages c'est dame
prend h7 comprend hc3 prend h7 est
peut-être à des trucs
ouais c'est pas directement un jour
c'est sympa d'être 3 kw à tapas ou
problème de la cause de ton problème de
toujours aidé à me 6 mai ils rentrent
fait c'est pas si claire quoi ça c'est
dans sa connerie il est tellement bien
que en fait même avec un coup de moins
mais je crois qu'on a quand il s'est
fait avoir
enfin il pensait que faire flamber six
dessins qu'ils allaient faire entrer le
fou et c'était fini et il a bien oublié
qu'ils pouvaient jamais prendre en f2 en
fait c'est super bien ce qu'il a fait il
revenait de prendre f2
ouais c'était bien joué les tours 8
mais attends il n'y a pas d'âme h7 d'un
prochain tour h trois tours h6 est prise
à 6 t shirts bleu ou dans le sens
amesterdam achètent-ils le roi et fuite
ah c'est toute la finesse du tour 8 en
fait c'est tellement bien joué ouais non
la naca grand bonhomme un pro tour 8
c'était tellement malin que maintenant
que trois noms trois croix bien c'était
une connerie c'est sûr parce qu'en plus
on roi il serait même mieux de pas un
moment donné tu et est dégoûté mise
pasqua sur trois il doit y avoir un
problème h pas de ma chute vous vous
ferez 7j 7
aouidat matches huit bouffées g7 a oui
mais c'est très bien joué c'est encore
j'avais pas vu ou l'arrêter non mais ça
c'est pas possible qu'elle ait jamais
apprise prisé g7 déjà qui donne envie
prix cerise et gsm très envie de 2 308
on sera encore dans le premier set se
dire oui
ménagé cette maintenant on est un peu
pris de toutes parts hu
oui enfin c'est craquage il y avait donc
reprendre les tournages suite madoff
oui mais après j'ai coûté deux points
d'avance mesalles là j'ai envie de te
dire elle fait vraiment mal parce que
soit gaffes et rappelle que j'ai est
malgré tout et nakata l'impression qu'il
sortait la grosse défense et finalement
bombe
j'étais pris par le temps c'est rare
dont il a été pris par le temps
d'ailleurs t'as raison de le souligner
non il n'était pas a super bien été dur
à défendre mais c'est vrai qu'il est et
il a carrément plus de temps à la fin
complètement nuls
mais même le dame prend 17 juin il le
voit quand même assez vite c'est pas
simple comme coup bah écoute j'ai envie
de te dire que wesley il a vite répondu
à notre question la question elle a été
vite répondu de qui est favori
ballaman on a un gros match parce que
n'a qu'à laval en retard pour les bullet
il va devoir alors sortir une grosse
session en plus un peu limité la casse
avant la se dire est ce que ce n'est pas
le karma qui me frappe après la victoire
très moche contre le joueur français
hier je n'aurais peut-être pas dû faire
ça mr d ieu game that cost mijote
goisque ahmad askar bat donc cette
petite espagnole qui ressemble plus à
une italienne qu'autre chose bailly on
sait pas trop ce qu'il veut faire son
roi quoi le garde au centre pour ce que
chez petit rock ce que je fais grand
roque là pour le coup tu peux dire va
peut-être donner du grand paris nous a
pas toujours appris que quand le mec
avait par roque et fallait jamais joué
g5 ce qu'il faut être fair grand roque
et h4 est pas un truc comme ça tu vas
normalement c'est ça l'idée après bon tu
fais h 4 et tu feras chez kbc de bloquer
mais a priori la carrière du groupe
donc les gars ne fait jamais ça chez
vous et ceux réalisés par des
professionnels et je pense que le
processus que sur un an + / cavaliers
prend 1,5 à l'étranger 3 qui prend ses
six pour attaquer la dame il ya doit y
avoir des processus pour contre attaquer
le fou ou alors de la vigne mais pas
trop
paris fait qaïda ça va logique logique
tu peux pas trop grand ok alors comment
gers avec avec les noirs c'est parce que
si simple assez heureux d'être un roi g7
comme ça histoire quand même de
solidifier ce qui est celui viable
j'aime pas du tout les noirs or la mort
df ce souk et au rock ça te paraît quand
même être un coup soit il mange un truc
mon poing salade
ce n'est pas une pomme h trois arrivées
éviter les fous gkd imagine vous voulez
g4 bon en fait soit hyper désagréable
pour les blancs c'est la partie ii
capable en cas quoi c'est si tu es fou
g4 bref trois qui agit prend mais bon
accueil en d2 c'est pas censé arriver
bon il se dirige vers kg s'y soumettre
un cavaleur 4 bien comme il faut et à
peut-être aussi un monde et c6 b5 et
pour envoyer car il est un jeu très bien
joué attac lecavalier et prépare kg 4
exactement a cédé joli coup 1
du coup son projet 3d hyper contente
doubler les pions parce que tu auras
touré feinte un super contrôle donc qui
avait quatre c'est normalement je mange
au rock ça me paraît logique et puis
pour des géants et g3 et tout ça est
calme à deux doigts avec les noirs
d'être perdants je pense que tu es
tellement en retard de doigts quel est
l'étalon parce que c'est des doigts de
mazo ces jo maso tu as encore de
l'espace pour vivre
parce que les noirs ils sont ils sont
très en retard sur leur attaquant
regarder les blancs ils ont déjà le fou
en v3 qui est bien placé le cavalier qui
arrive en g4 il va voir un petit
jetterait ce peut-être pourvu la colonne
g ils ont même peut-être cavaliers f3
ici comme idée avec karelia 4 pour venir
même si ça j'y crois pas trop mais bon
cavalier f3 des cats peut aussi être un
truc
bon moi je préfère jouer la pression
avec les plans normalement mais c'est
peut-être plus plus compliqué qu'il n'y
paraît mais bon cela dit si peu près
autant faut jouer comme les normales en
fait partie mais j'imagine tu dis ça ni
museau vishwa un tarrach une fabien les
viser 6 complète qui crise ils n'ont
mais en fait je sais pas tu as colonnes
j'ai quoi bon on voit bien de faire
tourner un g3 où ça fait plaisir mais
faut encore continuer attaque quoi c'est
pas non plus si simple au travers duquel
g6 il va venir et non plus tôt les spas
68 et puis de l'autre côté tu es pas
complètement saïf non non c'est vrai
c'est vrai mais visuellement c'est
tellement ouais c'est ça quand on dit
ces cascades ont été réalisés par des
professionnels à machin c'est un peu et
luca en fait c'est qu'il savait vraiment
ce qu'ils en pensent c'est pas le genre
et prendre des risques comme ça au
hasard
t'imagines peut faire un à trois b 3 1
jour 1 et des 5 kg on prend et au cas où
k et damas et peut-être même maintenant
en fait parce que ta main tu feras dame
prend 1,2 enfin c'est terrible en fait
c'est une bonne idée mais peut-être à 3
juste ignorent ils te laissent faire à b
ouais bon dieu que ce qu'on a
actuellement ce sont louis oui bien sûr
bien sûr mais j'ai peut-être qu'il doit
même pas faire battre en fait peut-être
qui doit te dire ok je mets mon pions
mais kg 6 comme en province c'est comme
ça qu'on aimerait faire h 4 h 5 mg kg 4
et peut-être maintenant plus il peut te
faire un moment d'autres peut être
maintenant ou quoi mais peux même te
faire un fou prend g4 alger est en fait
le temps que tu reviennes se mobiliser
sur la colonne h il a peut-être le temps
de tomates et de l'autre côté parce que
fuji gaza qui te clôture la colonne j'ai
ainsi que le fait
d'ailleurs il va te auquel n'a pas le d5
parce que tu auras fou prend des cinq
mais alors tout cas les caisses doivent
elles sont sympas bas à prouver je pense
va le faire mais je pense à apprendre et
tué de façon sûre dame prend b2 tafua 3
et après on va réfléchir
suite à donner à tout ça mais aussi on a
le droit de faire un toit fb vite tour
je sais pas quoi et couvrez avec le roi
ouais en recettes et safe en plus sur
cases noires et ben wallace ans s'est
pas encore si salle parce que j'ai pris
six tours à chaque kg 5 ce qui peut
arriver quand même mais c'est juste
pacte un c'est compliqué qu'un prix le
juge ou à acheter un coup siens là je
pense que le temps qui viennent te
bouffer ces six là il veut dire qu'on
truc avec des cinq sessions ok c'est
chaud parce qu'en fait il est g h i s'en
fout complètement de revenir aux fermes
et les colonnes qu on prend du plomb à
mesa saint gobain servir jouer et
cavaliers puis fait rage 5ème étage et
si on prend j'ai pas mes cavaliers peut
faire j'ai hec intermédiaire parce que
tu as plus qu'à y prend b2 sur échec t5
intermédiaire alors là il ya de tout là
ya du f sinko dancing queen du flou de
bougé lieu des 5 mai estime que ce
serait mon intuition mais quand tu fais
pions prends tu défends 1,5 par la tour
je pensais que j'aurais cavaliers estime
qu à la fin et du ku'damm preuve que
trois
ouais mais qu'est ce que c'est si grave
ouais je pense qu'elle a je kiffe les
blancs parce qu'en fait avec les noirs
tapas d'attac avec les noirs ont été en
très très en retard regarde le foot est
roi en fait il défend une attaque
mais bon ça reste tendu un ca reste
tendue c'est une bonne tête mais non
pour prier car au bout il a grillé le
full méca c'est ça ouais il fait
peut-être il a trouvé le style option
qui devait avoir complètement fous rires
sont d'ailleurs à quel moment il s'est
trompé sûrement quand il a laissé la
colonne g s'ouvrir peut-être sur g5 le
c6 des cinq étaient trop rapides fallait
peut-être faire h5 quand même pour
maintenir la colonne j'ai fermé quitte à
perdre h assez dur à la foudre pour les
en détails parce que j'attends ça c'est
pas censé être bien pour les blancs si
c'est mieux c'est un peu mieux mais
c'est mais ces vieilles parties de
capable en cas machin états unis tu fais
juste chaussettes ou non mais c'est pas
si grave
non c'est pas si grave où c'est souvent
on voit c'est un poil mieux pour les
blancs sont plus espacées un contrôle du
centre sur ses positions je rappelle
j'étais très énervé quand j'étais gamin
sous son arrivée dans ses positions et
que les blancs comme je lé écossaise et
je vais pas chaque fois en dix ans court
oui mais il se passe quoi sur cinq ans
et on dit toujours en cours ou les
blancs sont beaucoup mieux ils ont pris
le centre tatort cité pièces et où a
joué blessé en partie jaoui vos proches
est mieux que rien enfin je sais pas
quoi faire en fait foi oui je suis mieux
beaucoup mieux oui on voit d'accord pas
les vagues on va sur foot il était
beaucoup mieux je tiens regarde oui mais
on regarde tf1 le kevin ne regarde pas
le centre wifaq et alors quoi
mais géant belge c'est très énervé ces
trucs là je suis beaucoup mieux quand je
crois pas mais réapparaissent les
dessins ou est ce que tu es nerveux
beaucoup moins de faire ainsi pions
prend tout reprend 17 17
pour punir un peu cette manière
désinvolte de traiter l'ouverture
pourquoi il a fait ça n'a qu'à l'ère un
fou à 6 un terrain complètement raté
cela je comprenais pas six ans et huit
avec saddam et sur qui et b5
bah écoutes je veux faire c'est 6 mai
qui a laissé cette ouais mais s'il veut
peut-être faire rock qui et b5 rock ok
mais ça je peux pas y croire en fait aux
pierres tard le 6 ou un truc comme ça
c'est pas possible ça c'est si ce n'est
pour tout bloquer les attaques mais
pousser quoi sur casque ailé 5 c'est
quoi ces basses et peut-être au
classement je veux être aussi fait
d'autres ou alors c'est fou quand dame
prend et c6 et tu récupères en 5 à la
fin ouais moi je pense ces six là le
débat non je suis d'accord avec toi que
ça donne l'impression que il va y avoir
un coût mais t'as qu'à une autre
solution avec les blancs y avait cinq
ans on va voir bon ok ce qu'il prend
ceux ci s'est bouffé 5 se profile direct
mais qui sait cette alors oui mesdames à
six mois après ce qui est ce qu'il a un
jet
interview aussi si tu veux du système
c'est qu'il ya cinq ans mais on n'a pas
de la suite mais il peut s'énerver avec
un pion prend des six souffrent b5
d'amasser 3 ou quoi mais je pense pas du
tout en fait au cas où tu la joues
modestement sont fait caillasser set tu
prends à 6
il va te faire sa structure symétrique
fera a4 a5 qui est un petit peu ce que
fait oui c'est juste que tu vu ce que tu
avais tu avais envie de plus punir c'est
tout en fait de tête qui a pas en fait
ouais mais en plus ou va-t-il texte à
plus 1 dans le match
une personne d'avant faut pas tomber en
l'air et put à la colonne d'états d'âme
à 6 en réalité je pense qu'elle est
plutôt bien placé là d'avancé
non c'est quand même mieux en fait j'ai
pas citer nettement mieux a été quand
même mieux ici ah j'aime bien parce
qu'ils essaient 5 gouttes échange tu
rentres en 17
donc tu es une pression voilà je sais
pas s'il va le gagner mais damas et
quatre mois
ouais ces trucs là toujours un peu mieux
mais quelque chose qui te fait rire
ouais je vois pas en fait j'ai trop de
la jeu j'ai envie de te dire pour moi
tant que ça marche la sait déjà c'est
déjà une victoire
en vrai je suis très content que ça
marche tu vois pas la cam ou quoi tu te
rends pas forcément compte mais je suis
très heureux tu vois pas ce que je
pensais pas que ça pouvait être exquis
aujourd'hui pour pour le truc
du coup du come tard dans quel sens tu
veux dire non mais je me suis dit bon
bah on va faire le stream tu veux tous
vous biennal et je pensais pas qu'on
puisse à présent même technique ouais
fréquentes chez his m'attaquer plus
l'ordinateur qui marchait plus ou quoi
wu et zi bowao françois notre ordi 2 0
annoncée
c'était réellement galère j'ai
réellement passé le temps de tout mettre
je pense de 11h30 jusqu'à 12h30 après
j'ai mangé peut-être de 13h30 jusqu'à
15h30 et encore et encore quand j'ai
lancé l'estrie a encore un problème de
micro de machins et normand c'était
chaud et surtout que j'étais pas sûr
enfin j'ai plein de problèmes incroyable
je vais pas te raconter les péripéties
ce que l'on regarde le match mais en
gros il ya eu plusieurs moments j'ai
pensé que ça marcherait pas et que moi
et que toi qui étais sur sa cigarette à
l'habitude que je sorte d'être que je
finis toujours par vous débrouiller quoi
peut-être que ça marche toujours
ouais c'était confiance et comment on
fait quand je leur les parties de vlad
fera quand ils jouent en direct
enfin je comprendrai jamais comment il
pouvait perdre beke 27,50 en face aux
files nuls fin mais c'est en fait je me
rappelle une fois il avait battu balla
poste particules avait battu molsheim qu
en équipe de france
non le l'ukrainien là à 27,20 où j'ai
pas assez moyenne cauchemar link ou non
mais c'est par maurice n quoi voyager
toute façon
mais qu'est 27 et calc ouais je rappelle
que le soir était content il m'avait
écrit ou quoi je vous fais jeter sur
calais bat comme un fou serait faible
quoi comment ça c'est bien qu oui enfin
que tu bats ta tels que contraintes
telles mais je rappelle que c'est
toujours très confiant en fait ce que
oui oui je voudrais bien voir à fouquet
c'est juste un idiot en face à un mec et
27 20 mai bonfim par mon avis il ne
comprend pas une grand chose du coup oui
c'est je comprends en fait on est fait
du yoyo il faut de façon
ok alors un ordinateur est cassé l'autre
aussi bon enfin en france en faire un
quatrième du placard qu'on va encore
vachement cnac à elle a complètement
égalité un ouais ça va bon il a encore
ses histoires de fous un peu moche mais
normalement ça va mary carré viiip de
carré lui aussi ce peut-être non puisque
sky vanilla un peu moche
bon du coup même petit vous prenez pas
pour condé et ours est mieux monsieur ce
n'est pas mieux ah mais attends
peut-être que cet échange est cool si
réussi à faire piéger à eux deux des
cinq enfants eux deux ces trois des cinq
autres avaient même avec le cheval en d4
ouais mais ce que tu peux pas le beauf
et ouais je jouais le déséquilibre
peut-être ce n'était pas malin de naka
de laisser dame c4 et chaque ce que mon
tour des huit tours de 5 à peut-être
aurait-on car ayant eu cette du coup et
je veux dire défendre et échanger
cavaliers comme cavalier je veux la
finale de fou ouais mais bon peut-être
un petit espoir oui alors bijoux
vraiment la finale finale j'aurais bien
mis la tour des simples dames et je
pense qu'il s'est dit qu'il a vu faire
food & cie ce qui a valu aux sept élus
chasser la tour a calé des six double
attaque
1 le jeu vite
ce monstre quoi je crois qu'il est très
heureux
charest caméra il a il a un peu souffler
registre antilles qui était trésorier
louis basse et bien jouer un ouais ça y
est c'est sa petite tête tranquille
bah ça sent la finale de foule elle est
nulle ça c'est sûr aller bloquer tous
les lieux mais c'est bizarre parce que
je suis sûr qu'il est hyper concentrés
dans les matchs mais il est très
nonchalant dans sa manière de fouet
c'est très étrange que c'est sûr qu'il
est hyper concentré mais extrêmement
nonchalant dans son attitude mais je
sais pas comment il fait même s'il a
l'air d'être à deux tensions machin mais
je sais qu'il a le coeur qui bat bien
mais il avait fait le truc à gibraltar
c'est un des joueurs qui avaient le
coeur qui battait le plus fort et je me
rappelle de sa non n'ont fait ni un
terroriste ou oui puisqu'en fait même là
quand tu vois la caméra et où tu dis
enfin quasiment tu as l'impression
qu'ils pensent à autre chose comme ça va
donner mais en fait c'est très étrange
pas assez bien sais pas si c'est bien
d'ailleurs ou pas mais c'est pas commun
ouais c'est pas le cadre
ak qui lui au contraire extériorise même
des trucs mais même des émotions qu'il
n'a pas bougé extériorise quand même on
ne sait jamais bien sûr ouais ouais
bosetti qu'ils demanderaient pourquoi
ils font des parties' cours tant
d'échecs sur un jeu de réflexion
bonne question mais en fait je suis très
vite disons pas besoin de des normands
pour trouver des bons coups parce qu'ils
ont passé normalement d'années de temps
sur les échecs ils connaissent très bien
les premiers coups et très vite ils
voient et puis du coup il n'y a pas
qu'une partisans font plein plein plein
plein il serait bien sûr que le mergen
attend vraiment ce que tu as fait a
répondu ragga dans le chat a pas
longtemps qu'ils utilisent et que que du
coup fait gagner en bis ne s'est pas
grande importance que les vrais échecs
c'était les parties partie longue
voilà un truc qui avait fait marrer
jouit d'ailleurs hussein bolt qui
viennent le 100 m enfin quel intérêt qu
enfin va faire un marathon qu'on va voir
si tu es si fort et tu vraiment rapide
la vraie course
bref études et vraie course et on ne
sait pas bon mais c'est beaucoup quoi
non c'est juste une autre forme d'échec
oui mais c'est sympa à suivre comme le
sont même d'ailleurs bonjour sur
internet on est obligé oui peut pas
faire des parts roulante sur internet
non sur internet tu peux pas je peux pas
j'ai déjà c'est dur de se concentrer
juste pour des particuliers sur internet
en réalité sans l'attention du je sais
pas mais auxquels font face les stocks
oueds et des gaffes en en partie
internet c'est assez incroyable mais
serait intéressant de les refaire dans
le point du point de vue que maintenant
les joueurs jouent plus leur répertoire
qu'avant sur internet de ce fait pour ça
c'est pour voir si ça continue ce truc
ou si c'était juste au début qui sont
habitués tout ça juste pour résumer ce
dont fabien parle c'est qu'il avait fait
des statistiques sur la force des coûts
des joueurs en cadence similaire entre
internet et la réalité et
avec des adversaires de niveau des
joueurs de niveau similaire et s'était
rendu compte que les joueurs sais pas
qui vous est moins bien sur internet
mais il faisait plus de gaffes en fait
c'est la proportion de gaffes qui était
plus élevée c'était pas le niveau de jeu
général mais bon aux échecs faire une
gaffe c'est tellement important une
gaffe c'est c'est changer les données ou
comme si on est donc qui donnait plus
souvent les parties en un coup et la
question s'il se passe quoi sur ces cinq
g5 l'idée ce serait sûr puis on prend de
faire tout reprend ffu 17
j'aime bien les blancs haïtien est ce
que tu vas faire à tuera du cavalier ces
quatre fous b2g a besoin que j'aime
toujours les positions j'aime du géant
pesant que naka et tout le temps mieux
c'est peut-être moi qui suis influencé
parce qu'on a un style plus proche ou
quoi mais gérard sont des mecs quasiment
tout le temps là qu'à hockey au début du
match vous n'êtes pas là ouais c'est
quelques parties ça va un peu mieux pour
lui cela le devient oui on a quoi on est
il irait dire est irrespirable 25
minutes de cette cadence il doit rester
cette partie encore 2 derrière donc bah
oui a priori les blancs ça a l'air sympa
parce que tu admires structure après
faut comme d'hab vous convertir il sait
jamais ce que depuis cinq ans taylor
sont très solides le key à 5,7 du rgs le
budget à trois derrière il ya cette
histoire de père de chou qui est là bon
c'est toujours une compensation ouais
c'est l'attend mais a donc fait regarde
si ces cinq ça passe un jour du
pacifique saddam et peut-être juste il
veut faire un truc comme moi je suis et
j'ai eu deux caillots soit ramené un
défenseur puis après contre qu'evian c4
il protège quand même le pion à trois et
il a atteint que cinq noms mais jacques
lançon bien je sais c'est peut-être pas
tant que ça quoi c'était pas si gros
c'est ce que tu souhaites nous dire
match voilà durrrr dwan avait définitif
sera position juste je suis d'accord je
prendrais également les blancs ça me
demandait de choisir tu faire votre pied
le côté l'ufc que choisir tu lui dis
choisissez les blancs quoi voilà
exactement mais 61 de consommateurs en
sueur parce qu'ils ont pris les noirs et
oui très complexe sera bien sûr une
rubrique fable que choisir c'est pas mal
en fait on devrait poser des positions
au nom de jean alors les frais des jo
les quelques couleurs en fin
d'entraînement quand on juge et la
position
ouais c'est pas facile en plus c'est pas
toujours facile de bien juger d'autres
plus qu'on ne tape la jouer la partie
quand même pas rester sur un truc tu
arrives tu regardes tu bois je sais pas
quoi lâche 5 c'est est-ce que c'était si
bien et si ça c'est malin ça tu as et
marlou je pensais que j'étais obligé de
faire un g6 je disais ça va pas trop et
en fait à six et bien joué samedi
protège avec le fouet 8
mais bon il se fait presser un parce que
ton ses trois tours c1
pourquoi tu joues avec mrm ce que t'as
pas de rupture pas toujours beau père
était très paralysé quand même ce que tu
as tout rang à 6 allée sous le viseur de
la dame
donc ça paralyse ta tour à 8
ces cavaliers tu es fou on sait pas trop
ce qu'ils peuvent faire le fou des six
il a aucune activité le fou ou huit
en fait c'est le fouillis qui pourrait
entre guillemets s'activaient mais il va
avoir ses six en l'air un jour non je
pense qu'il est vraiment pas très bien
avec les noirs après ça reste peut-être
dans le règne de thau nabeul alors ils
s'activent bien fait mais peut-être
qu'il y ait des deux dans leur tour
voir ces 600 l'air aussi ont leur qu'une
neutralité ce truc mais en fait c'est
que chaque fois qu'on le croit au père à
3 donc un jour là on a vraiment donné
envie de le prendre à l'état pas de
rupture katia id4 bonfoh kebbi 8 soit
tant pis on le perd en le père vous
aimait ça s'active et comme on peut voir
je sais pas trop quel coup je pars sur
cette option
well as raison tu files et tuffet cas et
dessins querrey s'est très bien joué
encore franchement je suis assez
impressionné par le niveau de jeu fable
de cette demi finale
je trouve que ça nous extrêmement bien
aux échecs présent c'est pas mal et des
bonnes décisions prises
non mais tu vois comme comme souvent
quand ça joue pas très bien où on est le
premier à le dire aussi tu vois j'aime
bien quand ça joue vraiment bien j'aime
bien le dire aussi parce que là je
trouve que la demi finale tient vraiment
toutes ses promesses et oued alger ici
s'est il veut du fou prend un stress oui
comme tu dis oui comme si tout allait en
fait qui a émis 3 qui a valu à cinq ils
ont été très forts pour gagner la guerre
à l'ale dame mais du coup il a trois
pièces écarté du jeu est maintenant il
va subir la contre attaque c'est sa
barbe on a quand même gagné un pion
c'est pas mal mais mais bon je vais voir
ma peur de chou qui compense qui peut
compenser un peu moins faim mur tu as i
te dirai si tu tiens tu tiens après kate
c'est un coup qu'on voudrait faire mais
j'espère qu'ils présentent c'est vrai si
on n'a pas un problème du jard fou prend
je comprends dam des cinq échecs et tout
reprendre et 6 à oui mais là du coup
fourré 6 pour empêcher sa écarts et les
c5
lévis les pièces blanches rejaillissent
il peut aussi retouches la case de 4 ça
va être bon donc france et 5 ça semble
être le coup mais si fou prend ses cinq
as dame bien j'avais raté évidemment
c'est un peut-être soit 2,4 problème
hausse mais l'entraîneur
et en plus quand tu es fou prend c'est
un tu vas protégé à trois ça à faire je
pense que ça à faire 3-3 bon fab
qualifie d' avance replica value 4 à oui
si on prend cavaliers prend tour ces
cinq cavaliers detroit sa de vie tout ça
et c'était pas prévu mais qu'à ce niveau
de jeu fab je suis désolé de te dire que
ça joue très très bien
c'est impressionnant dire excuse lui
dire désolé pour te dire on regarde
vraiment un beau match ah mais attends
est ce que tu peux faire food et de ici
qu'il en soit quand même pas mal relancé
pour le nord ouais mais qui avait laissé
six qui sait si ces tueurs fous des cinq
qu'elle prend 1,5 reprendra là et
excuses à tous les jeunes y ajouter 5 et
curieux cette nouvelle attaque de maths
donc
sow il fait une erreur parfois c'est
quand il doit défendre un truc comme ça
c'est en full passif y'a pas car il est
des cinq ici ah non il y avait tour à
tour peut-être tour là où les menaces
maths il ya les matchs du couloir
ouais des fois il défend trop
passivement et ça ne sert à rien il faut
dire mais ça peut lui poser des
problèmes toi gens-là bon je vois s'il
avait mieux à faire
entre larmes et la sueur première fait
que ces rapatriés toutes les pièces à la
maison aussi c'est peut-être une foule
aussi jeu parce qu'il voulait d'ailleurs
battu 8 jeux je pense à à perdre ça pour
les noirs ça se voit juste verte deux
pions de plus c'est trop ouais mais
[ __ ] pâte contre jeu ouais tabac c'est
marrant parce que tu étais en train de
le dire alors peut-être mais pas mieux à
faire
comme tu disais mais c'est ça mais il la
paix directes il a fait direct ouais
mais du coup ils t'avaient enfin si tu
pouvais le faire tu avais plus intérêt à
essayer de tenter un truc tu tentes et
ça marche ça marche ça marche pas ça
marche pas quoi binger alouettes
complètement parce qu'ils ont une finale
mais le à noter le l'excellente prise de
décision de nac après il faut prouver 4
de rentrer dans cette finale c'est un
super bon choix
ouais peut-être pour mon peuple a pas
dire du mal de son choix puisque la
guerre mais on ne sait pas du coup après
après 1h 1h 20 1h10 de jeu fab
impression qui pour toi et devant là en
terme de niveau de jeu il ya trois ans
et demi trois et demi qui mène aux
points assez chaud bas soit très très
bien commencé et puis au final n'a qu'à
se réveiller et écoute toi cette affaire
mais peut-être que la 4e son rythme de
croisière
mais moi aussi j'ai l'impression que
c'est un peu comme à la boxe quoi celui
qui met les derniers coups ils te
donnent l'impression de
de prendre le devant après à ce niveau
là les joueurs réussissent à bien
refermé la porte je pense pas que ça
fasse le même scénario que sow duda ou
lorsque sow était revenu au score contre
duda il avait juste gagner de tête c'est
tout il partie d'affilée
j'étais tout que comme je disais en
trois plus un sou apparemment il
vraiment c'est sa cadence
je voulais un peu comparé par rapport au
tennis aussi ou parfois tu as des
joueurs je pars quand un mec 30e 35e 30e
mondial e contre 1 6 est le gars vient
il débreakait qui lui prend le 7 mai
quand ça joue numéro 3 contre numéro
deux d'ennahda djoko quoi j'ai battu
mène 4-0 le mec reviendra de 4,3 c'est
pas pour ça qu'il va continuer bailly se
ils sont capables à très très haut
niveau de ce qu'on te répondre ouais ben
il sombre jamais en fait à ce niveau là
c'est si sûr insupportable c'est un
ouais ouais c'est ça bah oui badjoko par
exemple contre rogers ou quoi balle de
match à oui je crois que j'ai trois fois
de sa carrière
oui c'est impressionnant mais en fait je
veux dire par là que c'est des joueurs
de ce calibre là trop jeune il a sauvé
plus que trois provinces comme que je
connais des balles de match c'est
impressionnant mais mais voilà c'est des
joueurs les joueurs qu'on regarde là ses
joueurs de ce calibre là qu'ils sont
capables après plusieurs défaites de ré
élever leur niveau de jeu de te remettre
3 3 victoires derrière sur toute la
sauce joué pas mal hein sénat car mon
avis qui ya fait prêts à m'accueillir il
joue dépression un peu plus vendus quoi
il a un peu modifié son
son approche des partis un peu plus la
hisser les parties y voilà il met plus
de slice et plus regardent joueurs pros
aux échecs ou au foot je peux dire en
foot mais je suis pas sur mais sûrement
au foot mais plus rentables bien sûr
nous y ait une vraie concurrence
mais il ya plus de place après onze
joueurs sur le terrain et à les
remplaçants et tu peux être pro même en
alliant seconde division voilà donc dont
tu as plus de place mais je suis pas si
le ratio entre gens qui veulent faire
car dans le foot et les échecs c'est pas
quand même du coup je comprends et puis
après ça tu as aussi le fait que plus il
ya de l'argent et put et concurrentiel
plus les gens qui le font font de
sacrifices pour y arriver aussi
donc c'est toujours difficile de dire
mais l'impression est très complexe
lorsque tanaka bas qui envoient à fond
comme dans toutes les parties mais d'un
autre côté là il m'a l'air d'envoyer
quand même un peu en slip un bon ça va
mais ouais moment ils vont toujours un
regard de ressenti peut toujours voir la
position se retourne et puis la colonne
f qui peut s'ouvrir sur un cheval et le
cavalier 3 il défend bien parce qu'il
empêche l'arrivée du fou du cavalier
verger 4 et attaques des cinq est bien
placé ce cavalier mais surtout v6 il va
faire un des cuatro je pense ou pas
mme adéquat trop pourquoi ben que sa
fille est un pion quand même c'était
pour essayer c'est de vraiment ouvrir
quoi flatulences edc des fous prend et
tu as well as well as des gars comme
dans six centres s'ouvre tu finis à tous
avec toi il faut faire attention
et ouais c'est une nouvelle fois revenu
au temps passé une partie qui ressemble
plus au début de match dans la gestion
du temps et dans la jce papa dans le
style de position et dans la gestion de
l'ouverture où tu sens que choi là il a
un peu devant quoi je crois la pression
je dois dire tu as l'air mal là qu'un
soukhoï qui revient c'est appauvrir avec
les blancs tu es en train de suffoquer
un peu comme donc j'en sais rien tu
donnes pas la vie là c'est compliqué de
dire se voit je prendrai des noirs je
prendrai les blancs c'est marrant
j'aurais tellement pas peur on attaque
noir là c'est terrible
non mais c'est pas que l'attak c'est le
tout c'était pas trop taper trop
d'espacé que peut-être il peut se passer
un truc à un moment pas je vais dire
après il ya une position là dans les
systèmes de londres les mecs font un f6
j'ai 5 h 5
j'ai toujours l'impression est
complètement gagnant avec les blancs
c'est terrible après je regarde alors
dit fossé -81 fins et je suis déjà au
bord de l'abandon mais je vous offre
tabou c'est tout espions je vais te
défoncer pas mais donc du coup je suis
pas forcément je sais que je sous estime
complètement ces trucs là non mais en
fait problèmes psychiatriques et blanc
cinquième des quatre qui peut arriver
pour rire bâti les normes tant ils vont
vraiment être bien mais vrai que des
quatre arrivées et puis le deuxième
problème j'imagine sexuelle cinq paquets
pro 5 grâce à ses vues doit donc c'est
quand même un truc curie bien important
quand même faut le dire et la petite en
filature de la colonne et alors grâce à
ça je mets une pression je faire tourner
un jeu faire des quatre et il va quand
même
qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent parce que juste
pour expliquer aux gars moi dans ma
vision de la position j'ai l'impression
que
là le roi allait clôturer par les pions
il ya plus de rupture et que du coup et
que du coup en fait je vais au tour de
la fin il veut il veut faire fou prend
des deux tours en d2 qui a valu à 4 et
de jouer le cavalier contre le fou met
d'accord mais peu plus absolu heures et
18 heures heure du matin jour de moins
il va gras il va faire des quatre pouces
et 2 mais ce qu'il ya autre chose pour
les blancs quatre demandes et fils de
qualité maintenant est-ce que tu files
vraiment la qualité d'air ouais et là il
apprend pas parce qu'elle est toujours
un échec vous prendrez 5 qui allait
tomber ça allait faire très mal
bon du coup du couteau seulement huit
tours 1
je peux sur ce tour instrus de presse
après est-ce que la finale sur ans dans
une finale de fou contre cavaliers qui a
valu un f4 ils attaquent g2 les
chantiers charge par des tours bref tu
de regarder une tour avec les blancs
donc cercle surtout un va te faire
tourner 8 et donc hai-fu prend des cinq
tape à cause de roi des six double
attaque et ça veut dire que sur des
quatre hits fait tours 8
mais c'est encore une partie malade
c'est hyper dur à évaluer cette position
non mais en fait je préfère ajouter moi
mais c'est ce que je ferai c'est cd4
quelqu'un sait il est insupportable
c'est excellent
c'est exceptionnel ce qu'il a trouvé
naka quand même d'aller re d'aller
calculé le fou prend 1,5 pour trouver le
cavaliere 4 à la fin c'est titanesque
1,5 en vue de regarder non mais ses
coups il prend 2,5 et ouais donc lui
tout ce talent comme un fou scott se
faire marcher le truc ça impressionnant
ya un pas que le club leur nom mais il
va perdre gentiment fait tout ça alors
l'enchaînement f5 honnêtement est-ce que
tu m'as des grands maîtres en
entraînement tu leur mets à 15 minutes
il te trouves le truc parce que ça me
paraît vraiment hyper dur tu as
peut-être d'autres ou avant et en plus
ça il en partie sait même pas qu'il a ça
a trouvé ça me paraît impressionnant ce
qu'il a fait non là vraiment vous voyez
bien le roi est complètement bloquée il
ya le pion g2 comme on le disait on est
complètement bloquée avec les blancs
attentats pas un touriste inco c'est
précis autant mais bon tour et sinko
c'est quoi le bail ce que tu veux tout
reprend f5 et châssis chasse lecavalier
en fait avec les plantes est très bien
c'est pas surtout aux 5 7 tours détours
des cinq peut-être mais pas à 3,5 qui
protégeait bush sont rois ah mais en
fait ils pensaient qu'ils feraient tour
des cinq comme moi et il a pris un
nouveau tour 8
je pense pas je vois pas d'autre
explication en fait il a dû considérer
tour des cinq seuls coûts et les pirates
lors dit je te regarde et après f5 que
moi 0,44
les think they qu'il fallait pas faire
contrepoids le 5 mai tour prend 1,5 et
2,0 donc et on prend 25 c'est le coup
que tu veux jouer quoi en partie ouais
mais en fait c'est vrai que c'est plus
logique en tueur est une sas quand tu
prends à 5 et empêche tour des deux
camps bon ok ça c'est dur mais tu peux
comprendre
c'est horrible d'avoir près vous en fait
allégeance au drapeau ou ça sert à rien
paf fasse pas là que ces passerelles ou
là qui te fais la diff par contre tour
des 5 c'est quand même une option pour
prendre des 4ème et il n'a pas dû voir
en fait on prend des castes a dû penser
comme nounou l'aï complètement éliminés
mais bon une position complexe comme ça
c'est bizarre de de prémont oiseaux qui
écrit les chats sautent et femmes il a
dû se dire si will probably tech
probably plaisir où qu'ils aillent tahir
quoi elle n'a pas écrit comme ça mais je
pense que c'est ce qu'ils voulaient dire
rock texte difforme texti five i'll be
revealed probably primove rookie eight
qu'a bien jouer un foot il prend la
montage wemmel effet une belle série
quoi là il fait une belle une belle
série mais il joue vraiment bien normal
mais seulement il fait les mêmes
stratégies blanc noir maintenant on n'a
pas eu le même genre de position il
repas et ouais en fait ça lui a bien
réussi un ni la raison un bijou ce qui
marche un bijou ce qui marche et bien
joué franc jeu
c'est plus sécurisant pour le roi
bizarrement fin on n'aime pas prendre à
l'extérieur normalement mais c'est un
des rares cas filles auront le faire l
affaire d'âme d'un machin 6ème calme et
l'initiative devrait il devrait être
tranquille où on se la met il faut
vraiment qu'ils ferment la porte 1 parce
que s'ils s'y repère ça commence à faire
beaucoup trop surtout que c'est censé
être la dernière à cette cadence
à cette cadence ça dépend si elle dure
où passent pas sûr à 100% le sens être
la dernière et du coup ça fait mal sirat
quoi ça fait mal sirat bon réponse
écoute s'il fait quand même pression
beaucoup de fraudeurs c'est pas mal là
mais clairement il a repris la
l'ascendant
il a repris l'ascendant dakar mais bon
ça va être égale un ca d'un peu moins tu
peux battre
dois-je 5 6 nouvelles idées dans
l'absolu aux produits des 4 400 t'as pas
trop le temps est ce que tu auras un
jour là il veut tout stabiliser
adam 17 très bien joué près c'est pas
dur à voir au moment où tu joues mais le
truc c'est que c'est prévu en avance il
se la vie se bat il enlève sa veste va
se terminer
ces faits de jeu c'est en glisse t on se
mit costume c'est pas marrant et ses
fiefs il veut quoi il vous prend h3 il
s'en fiche en fait ils te le donne et
attaque 20 kg 5 j'imagine qu'un avocat
ch'tite ce boss et vite
basiquement ni rigole soleil tu vas il
se marre marre en quoi ils se marient
fait des petits signes de tête noni
fiant à dire qu il est pas content mais
pas content d'un truc mais par contre en
rigolant tu sais oui
ouais mais c'est à dire qu'il faille
s'en fout mais qu'il peut voir qu'il est
mal de fautes cherchait pas la finale
groupe carlson a pris à partie des huit
eric dane tour condamne tour ouais en
fait il se marre pas pourquoi je le rate
erdre quoi ils voient qu'il ya sermat et
ça fait mal mais j'ai toujours su que
j'allais perdre cette partie toujours
dit ce que je disais
supra je crois quand même je me
demandais ce qui se passait je te
demandais pas lui bon ben je sais pas
trop cher juste fois je crois bouger 4-1
tu crois qu'on attaque le cavalier tu
places aena caïd ans gardien qui danse
et qui sourit on sait pas quoi
qui va gagner ben on a cas quand il
danse c'est plutôt signe qu'il est bien
mais ils dansent grimaçant on sait pas
et ce y va voir sa caméra derrière lui
quoi il retourne tout temps la voir en
fait marrant toi d'être une manière de
se lever de se détendre vous faire un
piètre c'est être un truc nerveux tête
on va être chez des fois quand tu es
nerveux tu va checker des trucs débiles
comme ça parce que tu as comme un parti
quand tu te lèves pour marcher ouais tu
sais même pas pourquoi tu le fais en
fait tu fais parce que ça tough
mais je pense est fou g4 ici j'arrive
probablement à fo b3 sur fouge harry
noms préférant je sais tu dois je suis
lieu d'aider qu'ayyash 4 ou que ça je
faisais castella évident et c'est pour
se prémunir de la menace et avoir un
coût mais bon je pense qu'on aurait
tellement rien compris si on venait à
partir je serais fait défoncer quand
elle s'arrêter extraordinaire non mais
en fait ce qui me surprend pas si
admirable chez eux c'est surtout dans
avait joué vite des positions aussi
compliqué à prendre des décisions
ouais t'as besoin de temps le bon
puisque ce que je fous aussi ce que
j'avais une tour sur la colonne apprécié
de faire des cinq pattes as tu vas les
cours ont déjà possible ou g5 pourquoi
pas tu en sais rien mais fait c'est
chaud de jouer comme ça et des surtout
outre le fait pour nazillons ne pas
faire conneries tactique c'est hyper dur
c'est ça qui est fou votre de patron
cette première fille laddh de laisser un
machin emprise ou quoi c'est non-stop
est ce que vous allez lire
damages trois pattes fini des projets de
g4 à merde je fais est provocatrice
chaque marche forcée a déclaré les
dessins que ça serve à rien pour fillon
prend trop souvent on a eu la même idée
d' idiots quoi le faire une enfilade les
deux concours va pas je suis sûr que
pour eux ça paraît des idées d'enfants
quoi wind et elle aurait joué à un tel
truc très primitif
elle est toujours su qu'il ferait je
sais que là tu vois quand j'ai des trucs
comme ça mais oui tu es très infantile
enfin bien oui mais à quel point des 5
ok tu as ta case tata case f4 et tout
mais assez bien joué pour empêcher grand
roque en route pour l'instant est bon ce
chip ou non des assises a les caillots 5
en avant guingamp mais mon tour prend dé
6,6 à fait il a joué tout récent premier
mais il va être vous fait à six et b5 ou
campera f3 peut-être pas mais bon faut
prendre tout un programme
ouais et optiques à kazan ces deux mois
c'est trop mais bon cavalier ici je sais
pas face à un coup nous à de base dame
si j'ai bien aimé mais qu'elle est ici
je sais pas aitor price 3 mai grande sa
part est hyper fort leurs ouailles la
parole on est d'accord et sauvegarde
mais je suis rousse a pour le moment
mais je tape à l'oeil fatale pions
passés eux
t'as pas la case au 5e nul arrive à
faire un méta patrons français thomas
robert quand même si on veut oui dans
l'hérault a bien t'as pas tout reprend
ses droits
pascal adam qui ont trop la 3d on
revient dans le projet cadre de
l'approché dots c'est quand même
beaucoup plus à mesdames prend 1,4
peut-être d'ailleurs maintenant direct
mais bon c'est quand même wesley
petite bulle non mais c'est peut-être
pas qu'on juste au pays mort asie je
pense c'est une bonne décision aussi je
suis d'accord avec toi c'est quoi la
demande une fois le le chrono à tanger
les plus regardées si tu la manges et
surtout lucho time's up
ok c'est bac 4 paca relief 4 aussi qui
donne envie non
détrompe-toi active in détrompe toi
désolé pour te le dire mais nul est un
bon résultat ici savent appartient ok
bon c'est bien superbe heures 30 la
femme de match c'est bien tu vas c'est
là sans rigoler que tu comprends
l'intérêt du truc de 1h30 c'est pour des
matches comme ça oui mais son art mais
ils sont rares mais quand c'est comme ça
là en fait tu vois pas le temps passer
face est exceptionnel non mais en fait
ce qu'il faut qu'on ait un ce qui est
des cas où ils veulent garder ce format
là il fallait pas faire 17 pourquoi pas
admettons mais tu mets des ko dans l'air
près ce que je voulais si six d'affilée
s'est perdue ou des trucs comme ça quoi
non plus ça rajouterait une tension de
ces matches comme ça on imagine tu en
gagnes cinq d'affilée tu gagnes le match
et là tu es dans une série de quatre
victoires
enfin c'est chaud quoi tu es grosse
pression sa force aussi apprendre des
choix parfois qui sont intéressants donc
je sais pas mais ouais mais là ce
match-là pour l'instant y'a rien à dire
on s'embête pas c'est sympa c'est très
cool donc c'est
le la pause à la pause avec 10 minutes à
temps pourquoi les caméras qui se sont
il ya des caméras qui sont décalées de
manière étrange ça pourrait être
problématique
on va voir olly moss aurait là tout est
un problème mais mini problèmes récents
vrai
quand je regarde un peu
regarde un peu avec mon téléphone tout
est bien nazim aussi apparemment il ya
tout qui marche mais j'attends
confirmation
juste pour savoir s'il n'y a pas de
départage quoi 22h30 c'est fini 21h40
match pour le moment vraiment beau match
dommage et comme ceux des trois plus un
bon dos parce qu'on m'a dit c'est très
bien c'est son truc donc qui sait wen a
qu'à favori forcément puisqu'il mène
d'un point ils à leur achètent tout ça
mais bon t'as l'impression que le match
peut vite tourner dans un sens ou dans
l'autre
les niveaux sont proches c'est peut-être
un moment donné non enfin probablement
se jouer dans la dernière dernière
portion le but lettre il n'y aura pas
d'écart significatif mais bon après je
peux jouer au physique un an le bullet
aussi ouais alors qu'ils qui aura bien
manger du poulet qui n'a pas mangé la
peau ça après on le saura après le match
l'exact le genre de choses qu'on peut
pas on peut pas prévoir peut pas savoir
dans l'entourage des joueurs
complètement pense qu'ils sont parés à
six mois je vais à j'attends pour voir
ça
ouais ouais enfin en fait c'est sa reine
il me met son écran là je vois son écran
fait du coa ce je vois bien qu'ayant
partage mais vraiment l'échiquier sur un
quart d'écran nantis aux ti-cats ouais
tout petit vrais amis chaque et vient me
choque suspens sais pas je suis pas
vraiment est encore en vie après après
avoir mangé une plastique
la peugot me rien tout va bien non
mais en fait c'est un morceau assez gros
et assez dur quoi enfin ces territoires
fait ça
après j'ai regardé sur internet is que
les chiens ils mangent souvent des
choses non comestible ça fait plaisir
je comprends pas trop l'objectif mais
bah j'ai pas non plus mais le mangement
joue il faut juste comme ça
non il a mangé en fait non ils sont les
dents et à prisa va miser mien cette
pièce 10 de ce challenge que je suis
j'ai toujours dit que le plastic était
bon ok ça enfants dans trois quatre
minutes
ça représente 3 4 me de fab auxquelles
ce bon choix je couche toi votre nom je
sais mais c'est pour te tenir au courant
et tenir au courant les auditeurs voilà
non mais cette cool qui rend tellement
avec les blancs et bon écoute
à manger pour après le match nul alors
voilà c'est bien c'est bien l'écouter
planifier une petite commande sa
revanche quoi je vais manger une soupe
pho faut comme tu le ferais il se veut
seulement ouais alors moi pas du tout un
jeu dit faux mais il fallait que j'en
demande un truc ouvert
bon ça c'est bien ce ke dommage un seuil
mené 2 points
ouais il aurait pu maintenir la tendance
quoi ah ouais trop dur peut pas faire
mieux les pas bougé non mon égard d un
plus un parfum
[Musique]
c'aurait pu être cool puis plus plus
plus où on aurait pu être sympa quoi
bahman orange et l'ordi qui arrive
demain je sais pas ça arrive assez tôt
pour que je puisse rimer dessus ou pas
mais normalement il arrive demain c'est
une telle sueur je suis très content là
que ça marche
là ça va marcher et au cateau ne pas de
raison à mais là ça va continuer
jusqu'au bout et bas après les mêmes
bakic s'échauffer il va il va faire une
partie pédagogique après ça va chauffer
dans ce soir ouais il très chaud je ne
l'écrirai le très chaud wajid où il faut
j'espère un bon écoute c'est bon j'ai
lancé ma commande très hot house a
besoin qu'on vous montre tout ce
désordre souvent way to attack tabata
casser le tient aussi en même temps en
fait j'espère juste ok au moins que je
pourrais écrire mes données
ça sera bon ça mais j'en saurai plus
lundi en fait je suis quand même pas sûr
à 100 % ont le sens où chronos pas si
m'écrivent les étapes de ma livraison
mercredi 12h
donc c'est aujourd'hui on est d'accord
on est bien mercredi un colis prêt chez
l'expéditeur et depuis écrivent rien
mais c'est quoi c'est pendant la nuit le
truc qui va voyager pendant la nuit
j'espère qu'il va bien dormir quand même
mon ordi wave arrive et inquiète non
vérité écrivent ce matin quand j'ai pris
ils écrivent livraison le lendemain le
lendemain en fait avant dix heures au
cou tu dis les mecs sont efficaces comme
un fou d'elle en masse sur la main en
fait non le lendemain un téléchargement
dur mais du coup mon hésitation et sur
le fait que m'attend j'ai jaugé pas le
tchad ont du coup j'ai pas l'élite de la
nation pour me dire mais du coup mon
excitation et sur le fait de
dimanche deux ans c'est la raison après
de manger entre pendant une bonne salade
avait il raison qu'il faut prendre de la
force pour maintenir le cerveau alerte